Hey party people, I'm Bridget Daly at the ClevverMusic Studios.
Today, YouTube phenomenon Rebecca Black finally broke her silence over her Friday music video,...
...which is now up to almost 17 million hits.
She spoke with Good Morning America's Andrea Canning,...
...who, btdubs is the same woman who got the exclusive interview with Charlie Sheen.
...Rebecca talked about how much her life has changed since last Friday,...
...saying, "I can't even tell if I'm awake or not, it's crazy."
Black went on to say that the nasty comments she's been getting...
...on her YouTube and Twitter have been hurtful,...
...and she said she didn't think she deserved it.
Rebecca added, "I think I have some talent on some level,...
...I don't think I'm the worst singer, but I don't think I'm the best singer."
Seems fair enough. But this may be where we draw the line.
RB now wants to collaborate with none other than Justin Bieber.
She told Andrea, "I have Bieber fever, I am in love with Justin Bieber."
She then looked directly into the camera and spoke to the Biebs, saying, "Justin,...
...if you're watching this right now, would you do a duet with me?"
"That would be unreal, that would just like, make my life."
Now, Justin hasn't responded yet, shocker I know.
So, do you think this is a good idea?
We want to know what you guys think!
Comment on this situation below, and click subscribe on our YouTube channel for more music news.
I'm Bridget Daly, and I gotta say, I'm looking forward to the weekend, weekend. Peace!